[Música]
nos shows que ele fala é atribuído a ele
na verdade um dos pensamentos de que a
linguagem e pensamento são
indissociáveis
você não pensa o que você não consegue
dizer que você só pensa o que você
consegue dizer não existe pensamentos em
linguagem
isso parece que tem a ver inclusive com
um dos conceitos mais antigos da
antropologia de que o ser humano é em
essência é um ser social
o cachorro ele nasce cachorro ele nasce
latindo
já o ser humano ele aprende a ser humano
não é algo com que a gente nasce em um
caso curioso tenta um filme sobre isso
não sei se vocês já assistiram o curioso
caso de kasper house e house
foi um sujeito que surgiu em nuremberg
na alemanha no século 19
ele não sabia falar que tinha ele era
adolescente do final da sua adolescência
talvez 17 18 anos ninguém sabe ao certo
e evidentemente foi integrado à
sociedade ensinaram a ele a falar ea ele
contou ter oportunidade de contar a sua
história sua história dizia que ele
cresceu num quarto escuro penumbra todo
dia que ele acordava de manhã tinha um
pouco de pão e água do lado de sua cama
e ele não tinha nenhuma interação com
seres humanos e não quero entrar muito a
fundo na história dele mas depois que
ele adquiriu a fala depois que ele
aprendeu a se comunicar perguntaram pra
ele deve ter sido devem ter sido entre
aspas lingüistas na época não existia
lingüística ainda mas os precursores
talvez da linguística perguntaram para
ele antes de aprender a falar o que ele
pensava ou se ele sonhava era uma das
curiosidades dos cientistas daquela
época ea resposta o cruesp house parece
que vem a corroborar essas duas teses
que foram daqui eu levantei
anteriormente ele disse antes sob a
escuridão antes eu não sonhava eu não
pensava
por que justamente porque linguagem e
pensamento são totalmente indissociáveis
e frequentemente nós consideramos a
linguagem a aquisição da linguagem o que
nos distingue dos animais
na verdade o texto 42 da terceira margem
do rio ele fala a respeito no entanto
que existem animais
hoje já existem estudos que tratam de
linguagens complexas de animais por
exemplo vocês com seja ouviram falar que
as baleias se comunicam às vezes a
quilômetros de distância
as abelhas têm um sistema complexo de
linguagem e alguns estudos não sei
exatamente como eles conseguem avaliar
isso mas eu li certa vez um estudo que
falava que algumas raças de caninas de
cachorros da capacidade intelectual de
crianças de aproximadamente quatro anos
de idade para rechã que é um filósofo
judeu do século passado o que disse mais
do que a questão da linguagem que nos
distingue dos animais mais do que a
capacidade de atribuir um significado e
de nos comunicarmos é justamente a
capacidade de reconhecermos que há
coisas que não podem ser ditas que nos
distingue dos animais
existe um limite para a linguagem
existe um limite para o pensamento
há coisas que nós não conseguimos dizer
e nós não conseguimos dizer essas coisas
porque nós não conseguimos pensar nessas
coisas exatamente dentro desse contexto
que acontece à arte
o motor da arte a raiz da arte talvez há
centenas de anos há milhares de anos
seja justamente este encontro com que
resta chama do inefável o encontro com o
inefável aquilo que não se pode dizer
aquilo que não se pode pensar é o que a
raiz da arte
talvez seja por causa da minha
orientação religiosa que tenha
dificuldades em aceitar a premissa de
platão de que a razão e aquilo que nós
podemos compreender seja superior a
todas as outras coisas pra mim
justamente o que nós não podemos
compreender justamente aquilo que nós
não podemos dizer é que é o superior a
todas as outras coisas
ferreira gullar ele reconhece a
importância da arte para os movimentos
sociais é para a cultura para a educação
as questões pedagógicas a ao time
da arte mas para ele em essência ou em
primeira instância a arte algo de
percepção é algo que você percebe algo
que você experimenta e ele chama isso de
um relâmpago esse na verdade está no
livro de eli relâmpagos é um é como um
relâmpago e aqui eu queria contar pra
vocês rapidamente uma das minhas
primeiras experiências com um pintura
que não é a minha arte no caso sou
músico mas estava viajando com o grupo
no qual na época não tinha uma carreira
solo em 1999 estava viajando com o grupo
pelos estados unidos
a gente estava ali um calor no verão não
os 40 graus em och tom estava com a
tarde livre
ali nas redondezas dos filmes on-line
que aquele museu maior museu complexo de
museus do mundo né ea gente estava com a
tarde livre e não sabia o que fazer e eu
tive a brilhante idéia é a gente está em
washington onde está na capital deve ter
olhem a inocência da adolescente deve
ter uma galeria de arte aqui vocês tocam
eu com mais dois amigos vão perguntar se
tem uma galeria de arte aqui eu cheguei
no policial que estava ali na super
segura aquela região e onde tem uma
galeria de arte aqui por aqui ele
respondeu tenha na china o galo eo
voyage se você quiser me indicou o
caminho a gente foi pra lá e da maneira
mais despretensiosa possível eu tive o
primeiro contato real real na de de vida
adulta talvez com arte e foi a primeira
vez também que houve um quadro original
de van gogh é uma experiência que
entende perfeitamente que ferreira
gullar quis dizer com a questão do
relâmpago parece que um raio bate em
você você vê a energia do traço você
angústia desse homem tão perturbado e
aquilo a sublimação daquilo eu
compreendi a questão do inefável de uma
maneira como nunca antes tinha
compreendido talvez vocês não tenham
tido a oportunidade de ver um original
de um artista deste deste calibre mas
existe uma coisa numa melodia que às
vezes toca a gente mesmo às vezes em
letras vezes com letras vezes a
combinação dessas duas coisas
existe uma coisa que há
tem uma melodia singela pode causar seja
popular seja rebuscada mas ela consegue
focar em nós coisas que nós sequer
sabíamos que existiam dentro de nós e
ela consegue lembrar a gente de coisas
que a gente achava que tinha perdido que
a gente nem lembrava mais que existiam
dentro de nós
a arte tem essa capacidade voltando para
rachão
o mundo moderno a vida moderna ela nos
distancia desta experiência deste
encontro com o inefável a começar pelo
fato de você viver numa cidade maluca
como a cidade de são paulo que é onde eu
moro e se encontra o inefável se torna
cada vez mais raro se torna cada vez
mais difícil e inclusive para o homem
moderno a relação que nós temos com a
natureza ela gira mais em questão de
utilidade
a gente se apropriar do que a gente pode
usar o que a gente pode ganhar eo
egocentrismo do homem moderno ele é tão
arraigado ele é tão avassalador que até
dentro da minha raiz religiosa da
educação que eu tive eu lembro quando
fui lá na década de 90 no começo da
década de 90 no final da década de 80
quando foram me ensinar o verso amar o
próximo como assim como a ti mesmo muito
próximo como a ti mesmo com certeza você
já ouviu isso as palavras jesus que
estão em levítico 19 também na verdade
jesus está citando o antigo testamento
quando ele vai dizer isso a gente
consiga transformar isso num recado de
que nós devemos amar a nós mesmos
o século 21 é o século 21
a gente é tão egocêntrico que a mensagem
mais em prol de outro do outro e você
compreender o outro a gente conseguiu
transformar num recado à psicologia
moderna conseguiu transformar recado que
a gente tem que amar a si mesmo para
depois poder amar o próximo
eu poderia em se tratar de arte havia
tanta haveria tanta coisa que poderia
dizer eu poderia dicotomizar a arte
versus entretenimento e se daria uma
palestra de 15 minutos ou mais
eu poderia falar a respeito de arte
versus massificação eu podia falar a
respeito de como para a vida de um
artista no mundo das redes sociais
a própria celebridade em que você se
torna fatal nem
se você tiver algum tipo de êxito
inconteste com arte que você produz eu
poderia aproveitar esse momento aqui pra
dar uma alfinetada e talvez alguns
outros colegas artistas de que tudo o
que vale tudo que você não puder dizer
através da sua arte talvez não vale a
pena dizer erol
eu poderia falar que a arte pode ser
utilizada para transmitir e popularizar
conceitos filosóficos
no meu caso talvez teológicos que podem
ser massificados no bom sentido dessa
palavra popularizadas melhor do que mais
eficazes que podem ser popularizadas de
modo a talvez depois de um tempo depois
de uma geração produzir mudança social
mudanças de comportamento mudanças
conceituais mas pra mim quer queira ou
não hoje quando vou falar de arte é
sobre esse encontro do inefável com um
infalível e olha só que curioso
a arte é consequência do encontro o
inefável e qual o resultado de arte
também o encontro com o inefável porque
quando você está perante uma obra de
arte
você também não sabe o que dizer você
também não consegue dizer o que pensa
porque você não sabe pensar o que disse
perante a grandeza do sublime perante a
grandeza do inefável outra coisa
interessante em relação à arte é que as
nossas diferenças uns com os outros
também tende a diminuir ou até
desaparecer através da arte um diálogo
entre opostos é possível porque quer
queira ou não você pode ser esquerda
direita ou de direita você pode ser ateu
cristão mas perante a arte perante o
inefável nós nos descobrimos finitos e
não há nada mais humano do que a gente
descobrir finito e quando nos
descobrimos finitos
talvez exista a possibilidade da gente
enxergar que podemos viver a nossa vida
em função de algo que seja maior do que
nós
olha só
quando nós nos descobrimos finitos a
gente reconhece que existe algo maior do
que nós existe algo mais importante do
que nós que nós somos pequenos não têm
valor mas perante o inefável perante o
sublime
talvez a gente possa descobrir que pode
sim haver uma razão maior para eu viver
do que em função de mim mesmo
leonardo boff tem uma frase que eu gosto
muito que diz assim jesus
de tão humano só podia ser deus jesus de
tão humano só podia ser deus será que há
de mais divina e nós seja exatamente
essa capacidade de sermos humanos e nos
reconhecermos finitos e de por causa
disso vivemos a nossa vida em função de
um ideal maior de algo que seja maior do
que nós
será que em gênesis 1 quando a bíblia
diz que fomos criados à imagem e
semelhança de deus será que será que
esta imagem e semelhança não seja
justamente a nossa capacidade de
sentirmos pelos outros de vivermos uns
pelos outros
será que em mateus 25 quando jesus diz
vinde benditos de meu pai possui por
herança ou em que você está preparado
desde a fundação do mundo porque tive
fome e me destes de comer tive sede e 10
cm db
o estrangeiro e os pedaços de 107 160
repare bem ele não está dizendo alimente
faminto para que você se sinta bem
não está dizendo de água aos e dentro
porque isso vai comprar favores com você
junta a deus o que você vai conquistar a
sua salvação desta maneira o que o texto
parece indicar é que você deve alimentar
o faminto dará ao sedento por que existe
algo maior do que você porque você
por mais importante que seja talvez não
seja a coisa mais importante do universo
e talvez quando a gente enxerga perante
o inefável perante a arte a arte tem
essa capacidade
talvez nós descobrimos
que assim libertação da escravidão doeu
a libertação da escravidão de você ter
que ouvir tive que você ter que fazer
cada vez mais fazer cada vez melhor pra
você ser mais pra você ser melhor
eu acredito que a arte tem o poder de
nos libertar do que mais nos aflige o
que mais afligem a necessidade de sermos
cada vez mais cada vez melhores
dentro desse contexto neste intuito que
eu quero cantar essa canção que de uma
maneira ou de outra quer promover este
encontro com o inefável e também trata
disso
[Música]
meu desejo é tio e adorart o senhor não
somente seis palavras não somente checão
sou eu querer
[Música]
o
o teu caminho
vou seguir
e aos outros gols
leva o teu amor teu amor sol
em chat se honrar ai eu sei
somente chat
vou cantar
ei
[Música]
que haja poder nesta oração a
transformar o meu me lê tu és meu deus
meu pai de amor somente a tia gratidão
[Música]
somente em chat on high
eu sei
somente em chat
vou cantar
irei
o que haja poder nesta oração pra
transformar
do meu viver
tu és meu deus meu pai de amor
somente a tia gratidão
[Música]
ah
amei e
[Música]
amém boa noite
[Aplausos]
eu dava para terminar de um jeito melhor
e desde então é isso
muito obrigado por terem participado
dessa jornada foi absolutamente incrível
para mim espero tenha sido pra vocês
também
é isso aí internet santos 2017 e 2018
grande abraço a todos
[Aplausos]